bonsoir nous débutons par de très jolies
images de la ville de Nantes où il a
fait beau et bon aujourd'hui et oui avec
24 degrés relevés au meilleur de la
journée qu'est-ce que c'est
parce qu'on a ça
que bon on a un petit souci ce n'était
pas exactement ces images-là que
j'attendais je crois que la régie est en
train de t'en occuper de regarder les
canards sont revenus cet habitant t'as
encore du mal à réaliser ça a commencé
ici dans les dégâts chez elle sont
impressionnants en quelques minutes les
plafonds se sont en partie effondré
la grêle a transpercé la toiture à
plusieurs endroits encore sous le choc
elle doit aujourd'hui quitter sa maison
la poudre a aussi été très présentière
plus de 35000 éclairs ont été recensés
cet habitant de Billy dans l'Allier a vu
sa maison prendre feu après un impact de
foudre
dans tous les cas et en bas il y a un
petit peu d'eau qui passe à travers les
lustres de tous les luminaires donc dans
tous les cas j'ai plus de maison
toujours chanté alors peut-être pas les
plus jeunes mais on a toujours chanté
cette chanson sans vraiment se
préoccuper des paroles alors qu'en fait
elle parle d'une explosion nucléaire et
c'est vraiment les paroles de la chanson
allons à la plage oh oh oh oh la bombe a
explosé les radiations grillent enfin la
mer est propre plus de poissons puants
mais une eau fluorescente bamos a la
playa oh oh voilà c'est ça les paroles
excusez-moi le faux plafond de ce
supermarché dijonné vient de s'écrouler
leurs achats encore en main les clients
se feraient un chemin évacu en urgence
il n'y a pas de blessé les premiers
dégâts d'une nuit orageuse
les premiers dégâts d'une soirée d'orage
exceptionnelle du centre à l'est de la
France
ces flash quasi ininterrompu qui
réveille les habitants quand ce n'est
pas la grêle là quand on regarde on voit
l'impact qui est tombé
puis on voit un de ses cabossé on voit
qu'il y a des creux voici quelques-uns
des impressionnants gré longtemps et
hier et conserver par la voisine
Amandine
je pense que c'est ils ont dû prendre en
plus un petit peu dans la foulée ça fait
mal au cœur parce qu'on a retapé la
maison nous-même pendant 5 ans et puis
c'est vrai que là en l'espace de 15
minutes
tout est saccagé en fait il n'est pas
blessé mais sa maison était fortement
endommagée le plafond a fini par céder
sous les quantités d'eau accumulées on
réalise ce matin c'est ce matin que j'ai
pleuré ce matin là j'étais dans le
jardin au fond je regardais ma maison et
je me dis c'est difficile
tu as l'impression d'être tu sais dans
les favelas le truc où ça prend partout
non c'est pas possible et j'aimerais
bien savoir qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé dans sa tête intensité des
précipitations et bel et bien liée au
changement climatique parce que pour
chaque degré que l'on va gagner
l'atmosphère va se charger de 7 %
d'humidité en plus donc ça veut dire que
les précipitations vont devenir de plus
en plus abondantes sous l'effet du
changement climatique les cônes des mers
et le nouveau plus gros paquebot au
monde ce bateau de croisière construit
en Finlande pour la Compagnie Royale
Caribbean pourra transporter près de 10
000 personnes avant sa mise en service
en change les prochains le projet
suscite de nombreuses critiques pour son
impact environnemental rebaptisé par
certains le cauchemar des mers le navire
semble à milieu des enjeux écologiques
de l'époque évidemment c'est un non sens
écologique parce que l'empreinte carbone
par passager et l'une des plus élevées
au monde tout type de transport
confondus ceci il faut constater qu'il
reste une demande importante pour ce
type de voyage effectivement malgré le
prix malgré l'empreinte carbone et va se
paquebot a déjà un énorme succès et ne
zapper surtout pas car je vous retrouve
à 21h10 dans la nouvelle saison des
traîtres et vous verrez que pour vous
aussi la voix d'Éric Antoine entera vos
nuits je serai en compagnie de Jean
Lassalle de Natasha St-Pier ou encore de
Tibo inshape
que la partie commence
vous avez des députés la France
insoumise pas tous les députés qui
refusent de se lever au moment où Gérald
Darmanin rend hommage aux policiers et
gendarmes morts depuis 2020 revoyons
cette séquence ensemble
[Musique]
on va revoir cette cette séquence dans
un instant je suis sur le cul
de dire oui la société française est
raciste il y a toujours eu du racisme
on l'est tous un petit peu on a tous un
rapport à la différence à l'altérité
donc si ça se travaille pas si on ne
travaille pas de la curiosité si on ne
travaille pas du vivre ensemble si on ne
se reconnaît pas chacun évidemment que
ça crée des murs
c'est fort possible probable
Nathalie est-ce que je peux poser une
question et vraiment dans ma question
n'y voyez aucun jugement s'il vous plaît
est-ce que ça a changé le sens de votre
vote aux élections présidentielles cet
acte
je change pas j'ai pas changé depuis
puisque mon fils est marié une marocaine
et ça me pose pas de problème
[Musique]
allez ça revient un peu à ce qu'on
disait avec donc vous faites partie des
des victimes qui ne votent pas à
l'extrême
par cette citation du président Jacques
Chirac en 2007 qui me semble être
d'actualité au combien ne composait
jamais avec l'extrémisme le racisme
l'antisémitisme le rejet de l'autre tout
dans l'âme de la France dit non à
l'extrémisme d'après une étude de la
Commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme 15% des Français se
disent plutôt ou un peu racistes des
pourcentages en très forte baisse sur
les 20 dernières années en effet en 2000
ils étaient 43 pour cent à se dire
plutôt ou un peu raciste parmi les
interrogés les personnes les plus âgées
sont les plus nombreuses à se déclarer
raciste 20% des 60 ans et plus contre
seulement 6% des jeunes de 18 à 24 ans
donc vous voyez chaque fois ça paraît a
priori assez simple finalement les
bonnes réponses elles sont pas très
nombreuses résultats les Français
clairement surestiment leur niveau de
85% qui se trouve convenable on tombe
finalement à 58% qui présentent un
niveau qui est vraiment mais vite c'est
pauvre capitaine sont en train de se
retourner dans leur tombe
mais non
mon Dieu quelle vie merde bordel
pourquoi le fait ça comment ça va Jean
je ressens comme une sensation
d'éternité si ça peut vous aider Jean et
Christopher dites vous qu'on va tous
finir comme ça parmi les fesses
il y a un truc là-dedans je me demandais
ce que c'était ouais c'est vivant là
c'est bien vivant
genre c'est pas Saint-Tropez
j'en sais on va pas pêcher les moules
j'ai que que faites-vous genre
sauvez vos chaussures mais est-ce que
vous voulez pas plutôt sauver vos pieds
de gelure non mais ça risque rien ils
ont été gelés plusieurs fois
[Musique]
sur la salle mais je l'aime il arrive il
enlève ses pompes et tout le gars il
veut pas ça dire ses chaussures il
enlève ses chaussettes